so one of you offered me a video idea
start with one GP and buy items from
shops buy them and sell to Grand
exchange and see how much money you can
make in one hour I thought it was
actually not that good idea I guess it's
nice for a challenge you know to see how
much money you can make but overall
you're not going to make that much money
and there are better money-making
methods but then I thought what if
you're a new account like you just
started you completed tutorial Island
and you don't have really much on you I
mean you don't need that much you know
you have the Bron bronze Hatchet you can
chop some trees maybe kill a cow and and
and cook the food but eventually you're
going to need like uh better armors and
weapons you know what I wanted to start
this with 25 GP cuz this would make
everything much easier and it would make
more sense because I mean everyone has
more than 1 GP but for the sake of
challenge let's start with 1 GP let's
reset the timer 1 hour
let's go the first item I actually
looked up I'm going to be buying a jug
and that jug is going to go for like 43
GP in Grand exchange because people are
making jug of wines that is like the
fastest cooking experience in the game
so people need that people are filling
them with water I could do that right
now but you know the challenge is to
just buy items from the shop I'm hoping
at least 35 GP and wow that's how much I
got that is weird Okay I'll take that
that means I can buy now 35 jugs 1,000
gold is coming in if I can sell all of
these for I guess I could wait for more
but I don't know let's sell all of them
for no that was
one accidentally sold one of them
instead of all so that is almost 1,000
GP made in 3 minutes or so at the moment
we're at 4 minutes 42 seconds how much
is this cakon 76 GP hey you buy cakein
and you buy jugs that I hope that people
are going to be buying them cuz that's
kind of like an odd item people want to
make cake wait do people make cakes why
is it so much I may be losing money now
because of this cuz it cost uh 13 GP
instead of one GP as a jug costs
hopefully I can just get rid of them and
just to make this clear I am not waiting
for jugs to respawn I buy them I buy
kton I hop worlds please buy these for
50g P cuz I need to sell them now
because of
no 8 minutes and 48 seconds so far I
think I'm going to be doing two more
runs after that I'm going to be moving
to a different shop honestly I was so
excited to make this video but now I see
it's been almost 18 minutes and I will
have like 3,000 gold let's sell it all
oh look at the Kon I sold one Kon for 25
GP let's claim it 3 ,000 gold 18 minutes
this is [__] it's bad like it's even for
the new look collect ashes collect ashes
that that's like really good how much is
it 30 GP why why go buy jug when you can
do this not going to not going to
collect this on no the the challenge is
to go and buy things from the
shops if I get killed I am pausing the
timer cuz I don't want to restart this
again this is a quick way to get to our
down by the way you pull from Edgeville
you appear in in here I made a big
mistake I should have bought a vad
Teleport tab because I have no idea how
I'm going to go back with a home
teleport but then I have to walk from
lumbridge to vok which is going to which
is going to take me like 4 minutes 23
minutes by the way huh 3,000 gold thank
you a friend for this awesome video I
will be using this money-making method
to make money pineapple is only two gold
and even if you buy all of them two gold
I did not need to buy this I I did not
need to buy that many um jugs I I bought
them cuz I thought pineapples were like
20 GP each [__] like this is enough for
1,500 pineapples and I think you will be
able to find them in every single world
no one's buying them in this shop and
pineapples uhoh what is that guy doing I
don't know what he's doing not
pineapples definitely pineapples are
going for 160 or 180 181 and uh
chocolate dust is only going for 160 or
actually 140 wait let me check yeah okay
it's going for 122 so it's not worth
buying chocolate dust this is the best
item to buy people are using these for
super compost they put it in the bin and
it makes super compost I just don't
understand what people are doing in here
like it seems everything is in stock and
I hopped a few worlds and people are
just standing doing nothing are they
playing that mini game for a scarf or
what is happening I thought they were
broken Bots or something but that guy
was probably not botting by the way just
in case any of you are doing this do not
run when you have pineapples on you
because that adds weight and the more
weight you have the faster run energy
goes down so it's best to run when you
have nothing on you let's see pineapple
chocolate bar and chocolate dust yes
pineapples are the best 2 GP as well I
don't know how much I paid for chocolate
could have been more than that yeah I
can almost guarantee you there there're
more than that so this is what I'm going
to finish I think 58 minutes 52 seconds
so going to pause now while I'm talk so
we have 1 minute to go and sell
everything to Grand exchange but I will
not make it in time obviously cuz I'm
still here and if I teleport to
lumbridge you know what's going to
happen four five minutes to get to vog
but I do have have 2,000 gold left which
let's cheat a little bit let's say that
before coming here I bought a vok
Teleport tab so it will not take any
time to get to vok but I don't have it
so let's go to vok and only then I will
resume my timer and it seems like it's
it's going to be quite a bit of money
will I be able to sell these pineapples
though I don't want to go like too low I
think I'm going to go for 175
and if can they sell pleas yes look at
that and it's not even 1 hour well it's
going to be pretty soon 1 hour let's
claim that almost could we make I don't
think we can make it now no I don't have
enough money don't have enough items to
sell for that but you could say if I did
not waste that time in the beginning you
know if I I would have had like 10
additional minutes to buy pineapples
this could have been so much more money
but for a fresh account for a level
three account of course if you don't
include getting to varok initially and
completing tutorial Island it's really
good like it this is this is really good
money I'm going to be giving this money
away and I logged into I have a main
with 5 mil nice this is the classic
RuneScape conversation I know how to
make money mayor 999 level 38 with full
Addy this account is 3 days okay I'm
going to assume that he does have a main
I want to give the money away so this
guy looks very similar as well he's just
standing the power AMOLED oh that's like
the best amlet actually in fre to play
he probably afking not going to get any
respawns at all from him doubling all
money I wanted to give money to this guy
his [__] [__] is doubling money
mayor I have to report you now let's go
for scamming hope you get banned this
guy should be de happy with this 50k
look how he looks like what is a steel
simitar he's probably like very happy
right now in real life he was not
talking I just love seeing that kind of
people like ranged man 52 with full
mythal and a mythal long sword as well
that Cape as well hope he's what is
happening here though oh man I'm just
going to give all the money to this guy
here we go rang man 52 but he Bots
though this is like uh-oh too many Bots
oh my God thanks yes no problem enjoy it
all right so I want to say thank you for
watching this video it was fun to make
it this has to be the first guy that
actually acknowledged me if you did cuz
he kind of stands near me he did not see
anything is uh black pickaxe as well uh
yeah I want to say thank you for
watching this video I did not get bored
buying those pineapples help a brother
out homie no money left left
unfortunately what is this ice Poseidon
all right thank you for watching I'll
see you next time bye